married to the lovely beautiful and
talented Sofia Vergara you you and I
have hung out a little bit and you were
you know you're a guy from a real a good
guy but you're a guy from Pittsburgh and
I'm thinking you're married to this
exotic beauty from another part of the
globe did you take her to Pittsburgh I
did you take so if you ever go to
Pittsburgh oh yeah yeah oh yeah I took
her to a Steelers Ravens playoff game in
the snow and then I took her to Mount
Washington which has a beautiful view
and I took her to the place you take
everybody there first time to Pittsburgh
which is Primanti Brothers which is the
sandwich shop in the Strip District
where the old steel workers they would
give them like a piece of thick Italian
bread and then you pick whatever meat
you want they cook it up on the grill
you put it on the sandwich and then they
dump these big steak fries down and with
their bare hand they pick them up put
them on sandwich put coleslaw on top
another piece of a bread and then you
douse it with hot sauce and eat it that
sounds fantastic and and deadly as well
yeah so this is the sandwich that you go
to Pittsburgh and you prove yourself you
have to eat that sandwich yes like when
you're a kid growing up your dad takes
you there when you're of the right age
he says this is your birthright right
this is like your baptism your real
Pittsburgher now your real man now eat
the sandwich eat the sandwich yeah okay
this is your birthday what okay so I
took her and and and I said cuz what
happened like the year before I took her
was that well Hillary Clinton was on her
campaign trail yeah and she went to
Primanti Brothers sandwich which is what
you do when you go to Pittsburgh and her
campaign people probably said you got to
go to Primanti Brothers you got it you
gotta kiss the ring you gotta go you
know so she went and took a picture with
the sandwich and didn't eat it she left
and didn't eat it
that was the rumor yeah so I told Sophie
I said I'm gonna bring you and then any
brother you know Pennsylvania was a
crucial that was a crew that was a
crucial you saying the whole election
could have been swung
by her not eating a Primanti Brothers
sandwich saying we should look hit me
wish there were there were Russians
listening in don't worry she didn't
that's fantastic so what happened now
this is a big test so I split into her I
said listen I'm gonna take you here
you're gonna order the sandwich you
gotta eat it you can't look at it you
have to eat it this is my reputation my
face is on the wall like we got to get
the sandwich yeah and so they ordered
her sandwich they brought it over and me
and my mom was there we were both
looking wide-eyed right she picked up
the sandwich and she took the first bite
and she took another and another and
another and just like down the sandwich
in like 60 seconds seems like a
philosoraptor
[Applause]
you